here's 10 times that kilwa went way too
far in Hunter Hunter sponsored by
Squarespace the platform that provides
you with the tools to create your own
custom websites and online stores to
engage with your audience on your terms
but more about them later because we
need to see this pre-teen go overboard
and it really doesn't take too long for
him to start doing this we're talking
chapter 14 and then here's the situation
an old man challenges two pre-teen to
grab his ball ball singular if it was
plural we'd have a problem but it isn't
so we don't and the idea is that if
either goone or Kwa were to manage to
take the ball from Neto then he will
issue them their Hunter licenses right
then and there but at a certain stage
kilwa realizes that netro is one as
being a bit of a troll and he is so far
beyond the two of them that there's no
chance they could ever take the ball
even if they both relentlessly attacked
him for a year straight so kilo decides
to quit which is a fairly reasonable
course of action upon discovering that
your Endeavor is impossible however In
This Moment kilaa is anything but
reasonable he's incredibly frustrated at
his lack of ball grabbing and it's at
this moment that that he bumps into
candidates 390 and 391 and kilwa
proceeds to murder both of them on the
spot which in the manga is particularly
brutal you can see him having
decapitated one of them and sliced
directly through the head of the other
now in kila's defense there there is no
defense he went way too far here all the
candidates said was ick he's all sweaty
and Hey kid where are your manners and
one of them does go to grab Kil which I
suppose is threatening but it was also
Kila who purposely took off his shirt
for some reason and then decided to walk
straight into the candidates with the
sweat equivalent of 10 covering his body
and this was considered such an
overreaction that the event was heavily
censored in both the 2011 and 1999 anime
versions although the 1999 one is
especially weird because it gets
integrated with the whole Anita plotline
who was non-canonically exam candid at
111 and doesn't like them zics because
they murdered her Spice Merchant father
but it only takes another seven chapters
for kilaa to go too far once more after
Leorio loses his match and trick Tower
because he wanted to see a naked lady
the fate of our entire group is placed
on the Slender yet deadly shoulders of
kilwa his opponent yon is the dector a
man sentenced to 948 years in prison and
labeled as the single worst mass
murderer in zaban City his body count
total 146 victims across the entire
spectrum of age race and gender so you
could say that yers believed in
diversity above all but the thing is as
horrific as all of that sounds when
we're talking about the zics 146 victims
what is that that's like their body
count before preschool so kilaa responds
quite maturely and Assassin by
immediately ripping out Jonas's heart
and honestly it's definitely not one of
those occasions where you feel sad for
kila's victim however it's the face that
kilaa makes as jonice is begging for his
heart that tells me that killer might
have gone a step too far here because he
is relishing in this moment letting
yones live just long enough to give him
the despair of seeing his heart
destroyed and I should say it's not just
killer who has some red flags Happening
Here in the 1999 anime after Kil removes
the heart we cut to a reaction shot of
gone just staring at Kila in complete
Glee like a psychopath discovering a
fellow psychopath to go and have fun
with that's not even the only heart that
kilwa has destroyed in Hunter Hunter
though after a Stern talking to/ bout of
psychological abuse from his brother ILY
in the Final Phase of the hunter exam
Kila was feeling a little bit miffed and
we all remember what happened last time
Kila got frustrated during the ball
incident that's right he killed two
dudes and look on this occasion Kow did
temper his blood lust and killed only
one dude the very unfortunate bodoro and
fun fact immediately after this happens
in the hunt hunt volumes Togashi decides
to give readers a fun activity to do by
providing a dress up gone template
although in a weird Choice the 1999
anime tries to make things a little bit
less severe by saying that badora was
rushed to hospital but ah it was too
late to save him but the manger in the
2011 version no what's up there was
there was no chance he was ever being
saved it was too late to save him the
very moment that kill plunged his hand
straight through his chest and destroyed
his heart that's when it was too late
now in this case there is some argument
to be made about how much of this was
kilawa and how much of this was il's
influence but I do think that a lot of
people try to retrospectively excuse
kilawa from this action by handing all
of the blame to willamy but at this
point we've already seen kilwa murder
for much much less the way I read it is
that Kila knew he wouldn't be able to
pass the exam with ILY there and so he
decided to Forfeit in the way that would
best help his friends pass the exam and
Boro happened to be the very unfortunate
slab of meat that stood opposite Leorio
but not all kilow exaggeration has to do
with killing one of my favorite
character quirks in all of Hunter Hunter
is kila's very crippling gambling
addiction but there is definitely a case
where kilaa went too far by betting his
own life during Greed Island he did this
using the card risky dice a 20-sided
diey with 19 stars and one skull and
when a user rolls the Dy if it lands on
a star then excellent their luck
increases however if it lands on the
skull then it significantly decreases
their luck to to such an extent that the
user often dies very very unlucky so
every time you roll risky dice you have
a one in 20 chance of dying now in
kila's defense this was in order to win
a rainbow diamond card which as far as
we know can only be attained at the slot
machines in Dory City so kilaa saw this
opportunity immediately bet his life and
won first go and look if that's where
all of this stopped then this incident
wouldn't be in this video but Kwa then
got a bit of a gamblers high and
proceeded to keep using risky dice again
and again for an unknown amount of times
winning after jackpot until bisy was
forced to knock kilwa out for his own
safety if bisy hadn't done that I think
that kilawa probably just would have
kept going and going until he eventually
rolled a skull and died and what's
really interesting to think about is
that this is an instance where il's
needle didn't activate despite Kila
being in very real danger of death but I
guess this could be because kilowa did
not perceive himself as being in any
danger which makes it all the more
terrifying that he did this he was
risking his life but he fully believed
that he could not lose staying on track
with quirky kilwa again not every extra
moment results in a corpse sometimes it
results in bodies but bodies that are
still breathing and also bodies that
didn't need to necessarily end up on the
floor and by this I'm referring to
chapter 148 where kilaa briefly leaves
Greed Island to participate in that
Year's Hunter exam here kilwa runs into
a bit of an old buddy named zil he's the
one who helped G and kilwa navigate the
surprisingly detailed world of auctions
during York new city now look fair
enough Kila is on the clock he can't
afford to waste too much time getting
his license because there's all the
stuff on great Island to do so what he
does is knock out every single candidate
including zepo and thus becomes the only
one to pass the hunter exam that year
but he didn't just do this for the sake
of time in fact before knocking zepel
out Kil even taunts him by saying I'll
be the only one to pass this year I
added the but you get it he didn't need
to knock out zal he could have gone for
everyone else and there I think there
were over a thousand candidates there he
could have just taken all of them out
and leave his good friends appeal to you
know move on and get his hunter's
license as well but no kilwa is a very
greedy boy and decided to defecate all
over zep's hopes and dreams now speaking
of hopes and dreams the sponsor of this
video Squarespace actually gave me the
ability to make one of my dreams come
true which was to start a channel merch
store without repeatedly slamming my
head into the wall due to technological
illiteracy through Squarespace you can
sell anything through an exceptionally
easy to set up online store be it
physical digital or service products in
my case I sell physical shirts and I
promise you that we'll get some new
world riew on soon but Squarespace
offers an incredible amount of ready too
website templates that are customizable
to your heart's content through the
fluid engine the Next Generation website
design system to further unlock and
cultivate your creativity so you can and
should check out Squarespace through my
link in the description because doing so
will save you 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain and just
genuinely thank you so much again to
Squarespace it sponsors like Squarespace
that make producing regular fictional
Hunter content possible so please do
check them out but for now back to you
me now going back to Savage Kwa probably
my favorite Savage Kila moment of all
time is also on GRE Island where Kwa
grabbed a bottle of alcohol and created
a spark in order to set b b b why is
this hard it should not be hard b b b
and created a spark to set his head on
fire we're just going to we're just
going to go with the last one it's such
a brilliantly brutal conclusion to come
to the whole idea was that they needed
to force out of the ring but kilaa could
have done that much more simply but no
our boy again he had to be that little
bit extra and with this we also see The
Return of kila's sinister face by this
time he's well on his journey to being a
good boy but that Twisted appreciation
for unique kinds of pain is still well
and truly present and I also love that
this chapter features the Sinister face
from the hunter exam because in the
volume version Togashi draws Jonas at
the end of the chapter bringing
everything all nice and full circle
kilaa doesn't relax the brutality during
the Chimera Anar either although his
life is significantly more in danger he
still finds a way to go over the top for
example in his fight against mosquito
and this is one of those rare moments
where I think the anime actually made it
much worse than the manga in the manga
kilaa activates an assassin technique
called serpent work and takes off
mosquito's forearm in a defensive
position this isn't particularly
overboard in fact I would say that it's
thoroughly bored however in the 2011
anime we expand on this a bit the attack
here is translated as snake awakens and
instead of taking a single forearm kiloa
keeps pursuing mosquito and ripping off
second Li as well and seemingly content
were dissecting piece after piece until
there were ever so many pieces on the
floor but none of them are particularly
big or threatening pieces it's another
one of those killer with things where
yeah that was probably a more direct and
efficient way of dealing with mosquito a
lot of the time Kila ends conflicts in
one shot usually a decapitation but here
kilaa was content to take his sweet time
and just slowly dismantle someone
meanwhile against up kilaa also went a
bit too far but much like in his
gambling instance this was very much
personally detrimental rather than
detrimental to UPI so to set this up
kilaa had a uh how shall we say not so
good chat with gone this was definitely
the low point of their friendship and as
we know when kilawa is upset something
tends to die and so when kilawa came
into contact with up he said I'm a
little ticked off right now so I'm just
going to take it out on you and then
proceeded to smack the crap out of up
who was completely powerless to stop
kilwa due to how fast he was moving but
kilawa doesn't cause any real damage
either it really is like killaa just
hitting a punching bag he's not really
doing any damage to the bag itself but
the bag is also powerless to stop him
doing all the punching no one ever
thinks about the feelings of the
punching backs and then maybe you should
but kilwa gets so carried away that Gods
speed wears off and leaves him in a very
compromised position were if not
familiar on kilaa would once again be
dead now personal question how many of
you have a strange relationship with
your parents in some particularly
extreme cases a few of you may even have
wished that your parents were dead and
that would give you something in common
with Killa because that's exactly what
he did during the election Arc he issued
a wish to nanika to kill his mother as a
condition that is the condition was that
if they hadn't left the compound in 30
minutes then kikio would be killed so
you could say that kilawa never intended
for the death to happen it was all some
elaborate Bluff but he did still
genuinely put his mother's life at risk
and also there's a Sinister reason why
he chose her Gila has a not so great
relationship with kikio and even stabbed
her in the face that one time which is
why she was wearing bandages when we
were first introduced to her but really
kilow could have chosen anyone in the
zelic family in fact he could have
chosen everyone in the family there was
no need to discriminate but no Killa he
wanted to instead what he did was he
singled out his mother's life to be used
as the betting chip for his Gambit but
going forward now we have a slight
trigger warning for self harm because
we've talked about kila's Reckless
disregard for his own life enough in
this video and then we're going to do it
again because this is the ultimate
instance of that it comes from the hunt
hunt film Phantom Rouge where kilawa
genuinely attempts to commit suicide by
plonking himself on the tracks and
almost allowing himself to get hit by a
train he does this because he feels
feels ashamed at failing to protect gone
and he's also saved by gone who manages
to smell where kilaa has gone but it's a
it's a really dark moment and it might
seem weird and out of place and
especially in this non Cannon film
however it does actually have some in
series basis although it's something
that gets lost a bit in Translation in
chapter 286 there's a section where
meeron is talking to kilaa about what
they're going to do next and kilaa says
I already know that gone won't budge an
inch at worst I'll go down in flames
with him I guess and that well it pretty
severely undersells what's actually
happening here the specific term kilway
uses in Japanese is Shinju meaning
double suicide or love a suicide made
via a pact so kiloa is prepared to
follow gone down whatever destructive
path he chooses it's not necessarily a
pack that gone and kilowa have made
together it's more of a parasitic Packa
that Kila has made attaching himself to
Gone Going Down in Flames really doesn't
give you the same impression in fact it
makes it sound kind of cool but the
unfortunate thing is that there just
isn't a good English translation for
this statement and that's 10 times that
Kell went too far in Hunter Hunter